Those last two examples--"July-August 1842" and "6*9==42"-- suggest that we need more
control over splitting strings, because we might want to split on things other than spaces,
like hyphens or punctuation.
I'm going to introduce a tool that will help us do just that--a tool called "regular expressions."
Suppose we want to find all the numbers in a string.
We could make 10 different calls to string.find, look for 1, look for 2, look for 3.
We don't know what digit the number begins with, so we might have to try all of these,
but that could get really tedious really fast.
Instead we're going to use this new technique
that I'm just about to teach you--regular expressions.
The word regular has special meaning in mathematics and computer science theory,
but for now it just means simple strings, and expression is just a concise notation.
You may have already seen this in some math classes, but not thought about it in this manner.
If I write a mathematical expression, like x is equal to the square root of 4
or 5 is less than x is less than 9, each one of these admits or corresponds
to some possible values for x.
For example, if x is between 5 and 9 then it could be 6 or 7 or 8.
All of those are good. All of those satisfy this mathematical equation.
All of these match this mathematical equation.
Similarly, we often think of the square root of 4 as being just 2,
but actually negative 2 works just as well-- -2 times -2 is 4.
These mathematical equations are concise notations for a possibly large set of values,
especially if I do something like this.
There are a large number of possibilities--51, 51, all the way up to 89-2
and just writing this out took much less room.
Just as mathematical expressions are very concise and let us match or describe
a large number of integers or numbers,
regular expressions are going to be very concise and let us
describe a large number of simple strings.
Here is our first regular expression.
Bracket 1 hypen 3 closed bracket.
This is associated with the three strings 1, 2, and 3.
Formally we say that a regular expression like this matches or denotes all of these three strings.
The basic idea here is there is some symbol on the left and some symbol on the right,
and this regular expression matches each one of those plus everything in between.
For example, the regular expression 4 hyphen 8 matches 4, 5, 6, 7, 8,
and the regular expression A through B matches the string a and the string b.
Perhaps surprisingly, regular expressions are very popular and very useful online
and in computing in general.
Credit cards, phone numbers, addresses, e-mail addresses--
these are all handled by regular expressions on websites
you've probably all ready used under the hood. Let me show you a compelling example.
Here I have the form from the U.S. State Department for applying for a U.S. passport.
Regular expressions are very common when you want to enter structured data or structured strings.
For example, over here they regular that your birth date be specified as
two digits, two more digits, and four more digits corresponding the month, the day, or the year.
By contrast, your place of birth is more likely to include letters rather than numbers.
A U.S. social security number involves three numbers, two more numbers,
and then four more numbers sometimes separated by a hyphen or a blank.
An email address has to have this special @ character in it.
Regular expressions can help us do that.
Then an American phone number also has some number of digits broken up into various groups.
A billing address might have letters and numbers and number signs combined arbitrarily.
Regular expressions are going to allow us to make sense of this type of data
and also process it when we see it on web pages.